reescribe bien es igual a dos tercios de
x más cuatro séptimos en forma estándar
la ecuación debe quedar simplificada es
decir todos los números deben ser
enteros que no tengan factores comunes
además del 1 ok por un momento no nos
preocupemos de esta segunda parte y
mejor veamos si podemos reescribir esto
y es igual a dos tercios de x más 4
séptimos así que déjenme sacar mi
cuaderno de notas por la cama y vamos a
reescribir la tenemos que es igual a dos
tercios de x + 4 séptimos más 4 séptimos
muy bien así que la tenemos en la forma
pendiente ordenada al origen que está
escrita de la forma que es igual a m x
en este caso la pendiente es dos tercios
y la ordenada de origen joven es cuatro
séptimos escrita de esta manera es muy
fácil figurar cuál es la pendiente y
cuál es la ordenada el origen de esta
ecuación pero nosotros queremos
escribirla de forma estándar la cual es
a x a x + b y en esto igual hace y si
recordamos el texto extra que teníamos
en la parte de acá abajo nos dice la
ecuación debe quedar simplificada es
decir todos los números deben ser
enteros que no tengan factores comunes
además del 1 eso significa que en este
caso ha de ser en la forma estándar que
nos piden tienen que ser enteros y los
quieren de tal forma que no tengan
factores en común así que por ejemplo si
llegamos al punto en donde tenemos no sé
en 4x
2 y en esto igual a 10 bueno pues en
este caso
este número este número y este número
todos son divisibles entre 2 entonces
aquí tendríamos como factor común al 2
así que podemos simplificar más esta
expresión dividiendo todo entre 2 y
entonces llegaríamos a buenos y divido
4x entre 2 llegarían a 2x si divido 2 y
entre 2 bueno llegaría a james y si / 10
/ 2 bueno llegaría a 5 así que en este
caso la forma que nos están pidiendo es
justo esta que tenemos aquí porque así
es más fácil para el sitio saber que
esta es la respuesta correcta ya que hay
muchas maneras de escribir esto en esta
forma de arriba así que veamos si
podemos llegar a esto y escribir esta de
forma estándar así que para eso voy a
quitar todo esto que hemos escrito y
vamos a trabajar con nuestro problema
original
así que la primera cosa que me gustaría
hacer es bueno existen muchas formas en
las que tú puedes llegar al resultado
la primera que puedes intentar es
reescribir estas fracciones y la mejor
manera para quitar estas fracciones es
multiplicar todo por 3 y por 7 si tú
multiplicas por 3 vamos a eliminar esta
fracción y si tú multiplicas por 7 vamos
a eliminar esta fracción
así que si multiplicamos todo por 3 y
por 7 que nos va a quedar una forma de
ver esto es empezar con quién es igual a
dos tercios de x + 4 séptimos y si
multiplicamos ahora todo este lado por 3
y por 7 si multiplicamos por 3 y por 7 y
hago lo mismo de este lado multiplicó
por 3 y también multiplicó por 7
entonces que me va a quedar
bueno pues del lado izquierdo me va a
quedar 3 por 7 21
mientras que del lado derecho que me va
a quedar
bueno pues tengo que 37 esto es lo mismo
que 21 21 que multiplica y si
distribuimos este 21 me queda 21 por dos
tercios de x es veamos 21 entre 3 y 7
por 214 me quedarían 14 x + 21 entre 7
es 3 x 4 es 12
y entonces de esta manera hemos quitado
las fracciones y ahora intentemos llegar
a la forma estándar queremos tener todas
las equis y todas las 10 en el mismo
lado y para eso intentemos pasar este 14
x del lado izquierdo veamos si podemos
hacer esto y bueno para hacer esto vamos
a eliminar este 14 x de aquí restando 14
x así que del lado derecho voy a restar
14 x y si lo hago del lado derecho voy a
hacer lo mismo del lado izquierdo
también aquí voy a restar 14 x
y ahora que obtengo bueno pues veamos
del lado izquierdo me va a quedar menos
14 x menos 14 x más 21 james más 21 y
esto va a ser igual estos dos se
cancelan recuerda que reste 14 x para
eliminar este de aquí y entonces me
queda igual a 2 a 12 ahora veamos es
esta es la forma que estoy buscando
tendrán factores en común el 14 el 21 y
el 12
veamos 14 es divisible entre 2 y 7 21 es
divisible entre 3 y 7 y 12 es divisible
entre 2 3 4 y 6 pero date cuenta que
todos estos números no son divisibles
entre el mismo número 14 y 12 son
divisibles entre 2 pero el 21 no 14 y 21
son divisibles entre 7 pero el 12 no
y bueno 21 y 12 son divisibles entre 3
pero el 14 no así que es la versión más
simplificada que puedo obtener si
tuviera un factor común de estos tres
números entonces podría dividir todo
entre ese número como lo hice en el
ejemplo anterior que tenía por acá pero
este no es el caso así que la respuesta
es menos 14 x + 21 james igual a 12 así
que esperemos que pueda recordar esto y
lo puede escribir en la respuesta de
nuestro ejercicio que tenemos justo aquí
y lo voy a poner por aquí mi respuesta
es menos 14 x más 21 bien esto es igual
a 12 así que es momento de ver si lo
tenemos bien
de lujo estamos bien